hello everyone uh i'll talk about next
browser today
it's a part of an atlas engineer we've
been working on
this browser for the last two years
something
and uh we tried to look at the world of
browsers a bit differently
so we've been a little bit frustrated
with uh the popular browsers like
firefox and
chrome or the more geeky browsers that
allow us to be
tinkering with the configuration and all
so
uh personally when i use firefox of
chrome uh what frustrates me a little
bit is that i come i feel a bit
uh imprisoned i feel like i cannot do
much configure
uh it's a little bit like uh this black
box or more or less
uh you could argue that okay there are
extensions but those extensions really
are limited
they don't really you can't access the
internals of the browser
uh they can't really communicate so much
between each other and they can't really
communicate with your system
so if you want to interact with
git or your text editor you can't really
do that very well uh
it's not easy so um
there's that and then other uh smaller
browsers
then tailoring to the more geeky crowds
and those are usually keyboard focused
minimalist
you can configure them with in python or
different languages
and those browsers well there are so
many of them actually they're legions
and i've been wondering i mean why
actually uh do they come and go
so fast uh and i think the problem here
is
a lack of abstraction with regard to the
renderer and really i think the what a
web browser truly is
it's a user interface uh it's a user
experience
that allows us to interact with the web
with the content but it's not
uh it shouldn't really be stuck to the
web render itself
so we don't really i mean it matters of
course but
maybe it is not all that matters for
browser
so that's what we've been trying to do
with next browsers so the the
key design decisions that we've taken
here is
one to decouple the browser from the web
renderer
that means that we support webkit and
web engine which is more or less blank
chrome and on the other hand we also
try hard to make it extremely
configurable
because i'm a geek and i like to
configure my browser
to to the very core and i like to
to make it to have full control over my
browser so how do we do that
how do we have a fully customizable
program
where we don't only expose an api to the
user
we give the program the whole program to
the user
so that they can do whatever they want
with it and i think for that we need the
right
programming language that means the
language is fully introspectible
that's fully that can be fully
moulded around and i think a good good
um
uh the right uh maybe the right language
here is uh language from the lisp family
because uh
those languages are extremely powerful
in that sense are very respectable
so which shows commonness here and um
well that's enough with the details now
just i'm just going to show you some
demos
and well you will see that for yourself
so
this is a um
no it doesn't matter i would explain
here so if i can start a browser
okay here there i go
um so first of all it's well really
barren
but uh what i want to show is this area
here
which is a little bit similar to
and oops
okay sorry about that
okay sorry so um first thing is that we
by default we don't show tabs but
instead we use an
approaches used by emacs in particular
we
list all the tabs or that we call
buffers
and what's cool about that is that we
can search them
so if i write wiki and geeks i can
further search my tab and go directly
to the canoe geeks wikipedia page
and we can extend this concept or what
we call the mini buffer
or like the address bar essentially in a
browser to actually do this for
everything
for instance uh say um browsing here
and i see there is this uh um
table of content here i can actually
browse it
the same way so if i go roll back
enter and i'm directly at the rollback
section so we can actually use the
this concept this fuzzy search concept
everywhere
so it's pretty cool we can even use it
to interact with the browser itself for
instance how many times have you found
yourself with so many tabs you
were really lost with them and you
wanted to okay let's hear just a bunch
of wikipedia pages you don't need
it so then i can just start deleting my
buffers
i can narrow them down to wiki select
them all
enter and they are gone
so that's much more productive right and
it's a very simple concept and
when you start using it everywhere it
starts becoming pretty cool
so uh that's essentially basics for the
ui or the ux
but as i mentioned before it's written
in common list which means that you can
leverage a language
to hack it and i mean by that program
every single part of it
live so for instance here i go back to
my repo
where i can evaluate code so if i
evaluate the function current
buffer i get an object here
which i can start introspecting and here
you get
this is a slide a slime for command list
this is an introspection window where i
get all the details
like the title or the url etc
um and if i go back to my buffer i can
start calling functions uh
i can say say set url and let's go
to my website and
there it works
um now we can start doing more
sophisticated things like i can define a
function
so i'm going to copy paste it it's going
to be easier
and
sorry where is it
[Music]
oh sorry okay there
so i copy paste this okay there so this
is essentially a command that
will repeat what i just did i want to
delete all wiki but first say i keep
doing this all over again
all the time well maybe i want to write
a function that will essentially
loop over all buffers match all those on
my wikipedia
and delete them all so if i evaluate
this
and i go back to my next window and here
this is the list of all comments i have
at my disposal if i start fuzzy
searching delete wiki there it is
and well it's double and it's long story
i'm sorry about it
so um and i can call it or i can
actually
do even better i can bind it to a key
um and if i do this
i can evaluate code even from within
next you don't need an extra setup that
doesn't matter so if
you come and evaluate and evaluate this
here
there so it will vary validated the form
now i open a new wikipedia window
first them and
i've deleted all the wiki just pressing
the right key binding
i've rerun the command again so i've
essentially
hacked the browser while it was running
a defining function about it to achieve
but you can do everything you have full
access to to the entire internals
um it goes a long way
down this road when you can start
extending stuff for instance
you can uh easily call to the os
components uh if you want to hook up to
get uh
it's very easy to you go on your
whatever github page
let's say this one and here if i call
the command vcs clone
i've cloned the repository to my
favorite uh to my local
project directory uh that's very
convenient we would like to extend this
a little more so that it actually
updates the page at the same time to
show you that you've cloned it
stuff like that um beyond that
uh uh we've also passwords man what
about password managers i mean they're
really useful i like to have a password
manager integrated to my browser
it's best for security uh very
convenient so
we've also simply wrote a bridge
to keepassxc and our password store
and depending what you got installed you
can just print copy password and
you browse here and first them and then
you get your password and you can paste
it
um then next i mean i can go on on
let's say bookmarks so if i want to open
my bookmarks i can also
fully search them and i can match
against some tags so if you look at the
uh at the end of the lines here the end
of the candidates
uh if i want to match say against geeks
and foss
or crypto i can celebrate writing
complex expressions like
um sorry um
and giggs fast
crypto and as soon as i close the
parenthesis
that match exactly those two types of
bookmarks uh
one that has foster gigs the other one
has crypto so
imagine you have thousands of bookmarks
you can have extremely powerful
um match uh tag matching
from within the browser
um whatever so what about um
let's go back to let's go to tour and if
i go here
i'll start browsing so i go to the
anonymity network and i want to go on
the main page okay so i go there i start
browsing
and go to documentation then i realize
all right uh i want to go back i want to
go back to the wikipedia page
so i go back to the history and go back
to tor
um now i'm going down a few more lengths
and at this point i if i go
back again and forward again well uh
i've written the history i don't have
access to the first
branch of the history which was the tour
website but
here we have a bit smarter we we try to
store everything we start
to we try to store the whole tree of
history
so it can essentially go sorry history
tree
and there i can actually display the
whole history of all the
links i've browsed and in a very well
tree
fashion which is pretty cool right so
yeah a few more examples so i think
well i think i've shared all things over
there oh bookmarks
yeah so if you like emacs maybe you like
old mode
something else you can do is go to your
favorite website
and if you want to in bookmark this
link into your text editor as an org
entry
i've written very small functions for it
and there
i can capture the link and this will be
stored
with the right title and the right thing
in my org agenda
so here i've actually essentially wrote
a function to communicate
with the other world by passing code
around
which is quite amazing i'm passing lisp
to an external process
and this is just one function it's
really trivial
that's the kind of power we can get when
we choose right language i believe
so that would be it for the demo and
well i hope you enjoyed it we have a few
minutes for the questions
so thank you very much
[Applause]
yes
so you mentioned um there was
a password manager integration is for
keepers xc
and some others but also password story
um
is there also password manager
integration for bit warden
for which one i can hear you
it's their also integration for the
password manager bitcoin
um oh okay thank you
um i mean of course so the question is
can we have
integration with more password managers
and of course uh
really that's the whole point is that
it's really easy to
to uh integrate with all sorts of
external processes
um and when it comes to the password
manager we
wrote a this virtual interface and you
can
essentially connect to it and then you
get everything uh for for free
can can the language be used to uh to
control the page itself like automation
similar to what selenium would do
like like selenium so automating within
the page
find the second link click on that and
then
fill in the text box and then click the
submit button can you do that kind of
thing
yeah so um what
really you can leverage the web render
to send any sort of javascript that you
want and uh what's
also pretty neat is that with a language
like lisp you can
have maybe you know you've heard of
closure script uh
common list has the equivalent called
parent script so it demands to
it compiles lisp on the fly to
javascript and sends it to the browser
so you can start compiling everything in
lisp but actually interact with a web
page
hi thank you for the talk is there a way
for to exchange extensions because there
are quite a security risk since
they have access to a file system don't
they yeah so
have you i'm sure you've thought about
it but how do you
exchange extensions and make sure that
they're secure
you mean so the question is uh so last
question
the question is is uh how to make sure
that extensions can be exchanged and or
secure
so you mean uh third-party extensions so
this
the answer is very simple for now uh we
don't have third-party extensions
but in the future of course we want
something uh very robust here
um i mean i personally work with a geeks
package manager which uh
provides a lot of security here so that
could be we could leverage
this uh package measure to to provide to
do distribute extensions
that gives you gives us a lot of
guarantees
thank you very much